[Musique]
c'est une journée très important pour la
communauté sa chaise de l'université
paris saclay une communauté qui est
nombreuse et qui a un potentiel de
recherche absolument formidable la
question posée est celle de
l'éparpillement des forces donc il faut
trouver la manière de fédérer ses forces
autour d'angers scientifique majeure un
terrain compte de la spécificité du site
université paris saclay cette université
d un mondial et dans laquelle les sss
ont un rôle à jouer important elles
peuvent profiter des l'environnement
scientifique tout à fait exceptionnel
pour cette raison la maison des sciences
de l'homme que j'ai l'honneur de diriger
et comme ça comme stratégie des portes
et l'interdisciplinarité non seulement
entre les sss alors l'historique pour
les un message le tel qu'il a été défini
par fernand braudel aux années 60 mais
aussi l'interdisciplinarité avec les
autres sciences et donc c'est un message
à une vocation particulière qui
profitent de la spécificité du site
cette spécificité et vient aussi du fait
que les industriels sont très présents
alors il est très important pour notre
message aussi dépenser les interactions
avec le monde industriel et pensez aussi
à la valorisation des recherches et ses
fils on n'est pas là pour jouer les
rôles des sciences comme caution
la décision des autres sciences sciences
humaines et sociales comme caution des
autres sciences mais on peut participer
aux réflexions en allemand qui sur des
questions et sachets savant d' orienter
leurs recherches dans les autres
sciences et les applications déclenché
[Musique]